previously on TV since you can tip it
[Music]
we'll get to the sin and shortly but if
there's one thing I love about Steven's
universe it's the body diversity look at
these four different beautiful shapes
different beautiful sizes different
beautiful skin tones it's almost like
the real world but with magic gyms and
such you guys better come check this out
you'd better come take a look at this
cliche the ocean if the ocean
disappeared how is the ocean floor
basically the same level as this
conveniently gathered crowd also this
boat is too close to the shoreline strip
club DJs this was literally almost the
name for Las Vegas so also where did all
the boats go
I said anyone figured out why Gregg has
a farmer's tan even though he's always
wearing a sleeveless t-shirt that we
used to call something else that rhymes
with life cheater but don't anymore
because we're more sensitive but we all
knew what it meant and saying camisole
just didn't feel right so we went with
tank top but that feels more like an
over shirt than an undershirt and my
point is the farmer stand is a lie wait
is farmer's tan also insensitive there's
a lot you don't know about gems Steven
and somehow the more their show tries to
explain things the less I know to burger
backpack brandishes bazaar bum butthole
[Music]
Garnett's rocky decision to roll to
avoid rock and roll
nearly rolls her head into a rock thus
ending her role which would absolutely
not Rock I've heard many people say this
show is essentially an acid trip and I
also feel like most people that say this
have never done acid because this is
pure [ __ ] nightmare fuel right here
you see a beautiful cylindrical ocean
and I say sharknado realized that's
magical destiny stop right there the
show summed up in one sentence and
considering magical destiny stuff is
basically waste a tease for reasons
let's go ahead and add 10 cents for the
show yadda yadda how this universe works
this is it lapis lazuli is here I don't
understand I'm with you pearl this manta
rays cephalic lobes look more like
testicles or boobs that's just not
accurate I know because I asked Siri if
manta rays have testicles and I'm pretty
sure I'm on an FBI watch list now go
away before I make you
I had a beach-summer-fun buddy once
my name is Peggy and we have five truly
magical days together then she ruined it
by recommending I drop ass and watch
Steven universe Peggy
not only the Steven refused to take no
for an answer he also gets handsy with
liquid lapis boundary Steven boundaries
study together don't
in separate since you're even Stephens
why would that matter I see Steve screw
has taken a page from the MCU as each
character will now fight a version of
themselves for the next three minutes
and in episode of Steven universe that's
like half the show I didn't lie and get
a double that's lioness define normal
lapis I'm coming up to see you so please
don't draw me well considering it
appears this water extends all the way
to space I think you're more likely to
have to worry about the water pressure
crushing you getting the bends as you
ascend here the lack of oxygen when you
get there but sure drowning your friends
they don't really care about other gems
all they care about is the earth an
insta B Nia truth this might be a little
weird right
so to heal her jewel he has to spit his
hand apply it and then she gets wet
again do I have that horny also this
works
okay bye what the hell that's it she
took the ocean cuz her gym bro he
happens to have healing powers and she
just flies off I'd say this resolution
is anticlimactic but there would have
had to have been a plot that needed to
climactic in the first place is falling
water blocks just like the normal
physics of liquid I remember this from
my school field trip days to Niagara
cubes what's that thing you always say
about the pork chops and the hot dogs I
believe the saying is if all pork chops
were perfect I wouldn't have to hotbox
in my bedroom to understand modern
cartoons wait did you say dogs
that's going to chafe my willy but she's
a gem just like us like no one seems to
be here school
[Music]
tell her if she doesn't answer you she's
gonna get Frank